I'm a minority right being black in the
UK especially I know how hard it is when
the majority think that you are in the
wrong and maybe that is that compassion
that I have for them because we are the
majority we have the privilege because
we were born as our gender so we have
the privilege to say no that's how you
do everyone was born
[Music]
the gender that we identify as but my
point is that we are the privileged to
be able to say that that is our identity
however some people don't have that and
I feel like being a minority and knowing
what it feels like for somebody to be
like no you're less than or no no wait
let me finish okay so someone's saying
that's the way it should be no I have a
problem with that because well no if I
was on the other foot and I was born as
a as a man and I want to identify as a
woman I would be pissed off if somebody
told me that I can't be what I want to
be